There's a lot that looks familiar in the
fourth "Matrix" movie, but this time,
Neo has no idea how much things have
changed. If you were blinded by nostalgia,
you may have missed these small
details in "The Matrix Resurrections."
"A déjà vu is usually a glitch in the Matrix."
During the montage of Tom Anderson's day
to day life, we see him eating noodles
at a restaurant several times. In
a small nod to the series' past,
the location directly parallels a line
from the first movie — and provides a
maybe subliminal clue to the audience that Neo
has indeed gotten plugged back into the Matrix.
After Neo is sent back into
the Matrix for the first time,
he's driven down a familiar street with
Morpheus and Trinity. At one point,
he points out the car window and identifies
a restaurant he used to like. He then spends
some time pondering how they never actually
happened and how his memories aren't real.
"God."
"What?"
"I used to eat there. Really good noodles."
Fast forward 22 real life years later and who
knows how many in-universe years, and Neo is
back in a simulation again — and dropping hints
about it by eating those really good noodles.
After meeting up with Bugs and the New Morpheus,
Neo is informed that he sees himself differently
than everyone else — literally. He's put in front
of a mirror and shown that, due to technological
shenanigans, most people see him as an old man
with white hair and a white beard. This part
is pretty shocking — provided, of course,
you missed the fact that we saw it already.
"If you want the truth, Neo,
you're going to have to follow me."
We're definitely given at least
one somewhat obvious hint,
when Bugs recalls seeing a man who looked
nothing like Neo but was clearly Neo.
We're also given a much less obvious hint, one
that requires a keen attention to detail. Pay
attention to scenes when Tom Anderson is in his
bathroom, especially when he's not looking at the
mirror. The Tom everyone else sees — the gray,
haggard man — is shown in the reflection. It's
brief, but it's there, and it's a neat clue for
either observant viewers or those doing a rewatch.
"Where are we?"
One of the first big revelations of "The
Matrix Resurrections" is that the machines
never returned Neo's body to humanity after he
sacrificed himself. It's certainly an intriguing
plot point, but one nobody would bat an eye
at ... unless they were familiar with "The
Matrix Online," a massively-multiplayer
online game active in the late aughts.
The game was meant as a follow-up to the
original trilogy, with the Wachowskis not
particularly intent on making a fourth movie
at the time. In a 2005 interview with IGN,
the Wachowskis said that they wanted an MMO
because — like their movies — it required
people to be active participants
rather than passive observers:
"Those are the people, the people who thought
about it, who worked at it, who we ultimately made
the trilogy for and it now makes perfect sense
to us that they should inherit the storyline."
Sounds like proof that this was
canonical, right? Nope. Ben Chamberlain,
the last full-time developer to work on
"The Matrix Online," told Eurogamer in 2021,
"I don't think we ever worried
about whether our game was canon.
I don't think anyone who worked on it ever
thought that anything we were doing would
be regarded as canonical in the
same way that the movies were."
This is just a way of saying
that the game is not canon,
despite massive speculation. The game
infamously saw the assassination of Morpheus,
but in "Resurrections" we find out that Morpheus
instead lived on as a leader of humanity
and died of other causes, leaving a
much-older Niobe to take his place.
But there's one detail that carried over
from "The Matrix Online," and it's the
inciting incident of the game: Neo's body was
never returned by the machines, and interested
parties want it back. It's hard to imagine
that Lana Wachowski didn't have that in mind.
"Nothing comforts anxiety
like a little nostalgia."
The first "Matrix" movie introduces
the dangers of deja vu via a black cat.
"What did you just say?"
After Neo sees the same cat twice, he's informed
that deja vu is a sign of a glitch in the Matrix,
an indicator that something's wrong.
It's hard not to get a sense of deja vu in the
fourth movie, which is by design — after all,
"Resurrections" is both textually and
subtextually about making another "Matrix" movie.
As such, there's at least
one overt reference to this:
The Analyst's black cat named Deja
Vu, who Tom Anderson does not like.
But there's one more instance
of deja vu that's easy to miss,
unless you're paying close attention.
During the montage showing Tom's day-to-day life,
we see a cluster of birds flying through the sky
multiple times. They fly forward before swooping
backwards. What's easy to miss is that the exact
same birds fly in the exact same loop outside the
exact same window — they're a glitch. It's not a
coincidence they show up around the same time
as Bugs and Morpheus, and it's certainly not a
coincidence that we watch a similar group of birds
dissolve mid-swoop towards the end of the movie.
"I remember this."
It was obvious from the beginning
that the Analyst was keeping Neo
placated as Tom Anderson. After all,
he was — in perhaps the least subtle
part of "Resurrections" — the
one prescribing the blue pills.
There's also another striking detail
about him: the blue frames of his glasses.
We don't find out that the Analyst is the one
behind the new Matrix until most of the way
through "Resurrections," at which point he removes
his glasses for most of the rest of the movie.
His glasses act as his personal blue pill in a way
— he gets to see the artificial world he built.
When he needs to get aggressive, he removes
his glasses, as if to demonstrate that he's
not hiding anymore. We do see him wearing the
blue glasses one more time — at the very end,
after Neo and Trinity break into his residence
and reveal that they've taken over the Matrix.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.